Die Mitarbeiter proteste gegen die Beteiligung am Pentagon Cloud Computing Projekt Jedi haben nichts genutzt. Die Microsoft Führung will an den Geschäften mit dem US-amerikanischen Militär festhalten. Dies verkündete Brad Smith, der Microsoft Chef-Anwalt im Unternehmensblock. Während er dort diplomatisch für den Standpunkt des US-Konzerns argumentierte, wird er in einem Interview mit der New York Times deutlicher. Microsoft sei in den Vereinigten Staaten geboren, habe seinen Stammsitz dort und sei mit allen Vorteilen groß geworden, die das Land zu bieten habe. Google hatte sich ebenfalls nach starken Mitarbeiterprotesten vor Kurzem aus der Bewerbung um Jedi zurückgezogen und nannte Verstöße gegen interne Ethikrichtlinien als Grund. Jedi alleine hat einen Umfang von 10 Milliarden US-Dollar. Der Bundesrat will nicht länger hinnehmen, dass Internetanbieter mit schnellen Anbindungen werben, die sie in der Praxis nicht erbringen. Er richtet sich nun mit einer Entschließung an die Bundesregierung. Die soll prüfen, ob erheblichen Unterschieden zwischen Werbung und tatsächlicher Leistung, Preisnachlässe oder Schadenersatzansprüche durchsetzbar sind. Der Vorstoß des Bundesrates hat aber keine direkten Konsequenzen. Die Bundesregierung muss die Forderungen nicht umsetzen und es gibt keine Frist zur Prüfung der Fragen. Die Bundesregierung will die zentrale Hackerbehörde CITES im kommenden Jahr erheblich besser ausstatten. Für ihre Aktivitäten sollen 36, 7 Millionen Euro bereitgestellt werden. Damit wächst das Budget im Vergleich zu diesem Jahr um rund ein Viertel an. Das hat Netzpolitik Org recherchiert. Ganz oben auf der Liste der staatlichen Hacker steht ein Supercomputer, der beim Knacken von Passwörtern helfen soll. CITES wurde vor eineinhalb Jahren gegründet, um Polizei und Geheimdienste bei der technischen Überwachung zu unterstützen.
Chaosradio 251, uns ist gerade das Pad abgestürzt. Alles was jetzt passiert, passiert aus meinem Kopf. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und wir sprechen heute über Hass im Netz mit Julia Krüger, Katharina Nocun und Luca Hammer. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück. Vielen Dank, mir wurde ein Pad gereicht. Wir wollen jetzt drüber reden, was man gegen Hass im Netz vielleicht tun kann. Und da würde ich ja zuallererst vermuten, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man das angeht. Das eine ist, wir filtern das alles automatisch weg. Und das andere ist, wir beschließen gesetzlich, es darf keinen Hass mehr im Netz geben. Was ist eure Lieblingsvariante? Keiner.
Ich kann dir meinen kleinen Überblick geben. Nicht darf, nur ergänzt mich, okay? Also ich meine, das, was wir im Moment haben, sind ja sozusagen diverse Versuche, es wegzufiltern oder wegzulöschen, je nachdem, wie man es betrachtet. Wir haben einerseits sozusagen das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz seit Januar diesen Jahres in Kraft, was die großen Plattformanbieter verpflichtet dazu, nach Nutzermeldung eingegangenen Hate Speech zu löschen, in relativ kurzen Fristen.
Also es sind zwei Hürden. Es muss jemand melden.
Es muss auch jemand melden.
Und dann muss es juristisch wasserdicht Hate Speech sein?
Na leider nicht. Also juristisch wasserdicht wäre ganz toll. Aber dann müssten es auch Gerichte entscheiden. Oder momentan sollen es halt Facebook-Mitarbeiter entscheiden. Die wurden zwar relativ viel aufgestockt, aber insgesamt gab es gerade in der letzten Sitzungswoche Berichte. Oder es gab über den Sommer hinweg gab es die ersten Evaluationsberichte von den großen Plattformen. Das sah dieses Gesetz auch vor. Also dieses Gesetz sollte zwei Sachen machen. Es sollte einerseits sozusagen das sogenannte Beschwerdemanagement von den großen Plattformen einheitlich und konsistent machen und auch dem deutschen Recht anpassen. Und zum zweiten die Menge an strafbaren Inhalten in sozialen Netzwerken reduzieren. Was die Menge angeht, kann man glaube ich gar nicht sagen. Weil dadurch, dass unklar ist, wie viel es überhaupt an strafbaren Inhalten gibt, kann man auch nicht genau sagen, wie viel davon jetzt gelöscht wurde. Und man kann leider auch nicht sagen, ob das, was gelöscht wurde, eigentlich jetzt strafbar war oder nicht, weil es kein Mensch überprüft. Das ist sozusagen das Problem.
Sobald er strafbar war, hast du gerade gesagt, dass soziale Netzwerke Dinge aus dem Internet löschen und hinterher niemand guckt, ob es gerechtfertigt war oder nicht?
Das ist ja das Problem, dass sozusagen, dass ich das halt keine Gerichte mache, sondern eben Plattformanbieter, die das auch nicht weiter an Gericht leiten oder an die Polizei, was man natürlich hätte theoretisch machen können, um so ein bisschen Überblick zu behalten, was mit dem Netz überhaupt los ist. Einfach nur die Vorgabe war, okay, was sozusagen von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern gemeldet wird und was die Plattform als nach dem deutschen Strafgesetz, also nach den Straftatbeständen dieses NetzDG aufgezählt hat. Darunter fällt, das wird gelöscht und bisher gibt es auch keine wirksamen Wiederrufsverfahren oder so. Das soll jetzt theoretisch verbessert werden. Aber insgesamt weiß keiner, ob das gelöscht wurde, auch strafbar war oder nicht. Das ist sozusagen, ist das blöde an der ganzen Nummer. Das ist privatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Aber gibt es, es gibt immer wieder Fälle, wo Leute, die sich quasi nicht zur Schuld haben kommen lassen, auch gesperrt wurden zum Beispiel, oder wo die den Tweets weggelöscht wurden. Ist das auf einen Missbrauch, das Netz-CG dann zurückzuführen?
Na insgesamt gibt es im Moment vor allem nicht viele Übersicht. Also sozusagen, es gibt insgesamt relativ wenig Fälle, die bekannt geworden sind. Und da, wo es schief gegangen ist, das waren meistens Accounts, die halt schon relativ populär waren. Irgendwie Titanic oder so. Insgesamt gibt es halt weder Stellen, die bisher sozusagen die Meldungen überblixmäßig registriert haben, noch die sozusagen Meldungen entgegengenommen haben von Missbrauch. Also ich hatte relativ regelmäßig andere Fragen von Journalisten, ob ich sagen könnte, wie viel Missbrauch davor liegt oder so. Ich kenne keine Stelle, die Missbrauchsfälle sammelt.
Wir können vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt zurückgeben. Hat es das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz eigentlich gebraucht oder hätte eigentlich die Gesetzgebung, die es der Forschung gab, gereicht, um strafrechtlich relevante Inhalte, die Hate Speech sind, aus dem Netz zu nehmen?
Na, es ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Also natürlich waren die Inhalte der Forschung strafbar. Natürlich konnte man die zur Anzeige bringen. Natürlich konnten die deutschen Gerichte oder die Polizeibehörden aktiv werden. Sie stießen halt im Regelfall auf das Problem, dass seitens der großen Plattform nicht so viel Kooperation da war, dem ganzen nachzugehen. Das heißt, die meisten Fälle versandeten irgendwo in irgendwelchen Briefkästen.
Warte, wir hatten also vorher die Situation, die sozialen Netzwerke machen nichts. Also jetzt mal übertrieben gesprochen. Und jetzt haben wir die Situation, die sozialen Netzwerke löschen alles.
Na, alles löschen sie nicht so. Sie löschen unterschiedlich viel. Und sie löschen das auch manchmal nach den eigenen Hausregeln. Manchmal nach dem Netz, die gehe. Und insgesamt ist es sozusagen nicht groß kohärenter als zuvor. Es soll jetzt theoretisch alles verbessert werden. Aber man muss halt sagen, dass das ganze Verfahren natürlich an und für sich nie wieder geeignet sind, geeignet ist, um juristisch klare Sache zu machen. Noch ist es geeignet, der Menge an Hassrede oder was beizukommen. Und was halt tatsächlich noch wesentlich kritischer ist, ist, dass sowohl parallel zu der ganzen Diskussion alle großen Plattformen darin investiert haben, automatisierte Filterverfahren, Content-Management-Systeme zu entwickeln.
Waren wir gleich.
Was jetzt auch von europäischer Ebene natürlich gefordert wird.
Aber lass uns erstmal beim juristischen Teil bleiben. Luca, kann ich da noch irgendwie Anmerkungen?
Bei Twitter würde ich sagen, dass es Netz.DG grundsätzlich den Ablauf etwas verschlechtert hat, weil früher hat man halt melden können, ein Feed verstößt gegen die Twitter-Nutzungsbedingungen. Also ergreift Personen, was auch immer. Die waren relativ weich formuliert, was natürlich wieder ein Problem für sich ist, aber grundsätzlich hat man alles immer relativ einfach melden können. Seitennetz.DG muss man bei Twitter jetzt immer in Paragrafen angeben. Also man muss jetzt sagen, gegen welches Gesetz verstößt der Inhalt jetzt überhaupt? Und das macht es teilweise wirklich schwierig, Inhalte zu melden, weil man da gar nicht mehr genau weiß, mehr gegen was verstößt der jetzt eigentlich. Vor allem, wenn halt so Massenaktionen sind, wenn dann irgendwie 5000 Accounts, ja, das ist immer übertrieben, wenn ein paar Hundert Accounts sich angreifen. Und es ist jetzt, die sind nicht greifbar. Also es sind ganz viele Meldungen, die eigentlich problematisch sind. Aber es sind nicht alles Meldungen, die gegen einen Paragraphen verstoßen. Und dann kannst du das nicht wirklich melden. Und natürlich auch, selbst wenn man es meldet, ist es nicht so, dass das Wetter dann tatsächlich löscht.
Man muss vielleicht dazusagen, dass natürlich auch dadurch, dass man sich mal anzeigt, sondern nur meldet, ein ganz großer Teil von einem Opferschutz wegfällt. Weil früher war das natürlich, wenn mal jemand verurteilt, war auch gut für die Opfer, dass mal Recht gesprochen wurde und auch das Recht weiterentwickelt wurde und hat gesagt wurde, okay, das ist legitim, das ist nicht legitim. Und hier hat jemand Unrecht erfahren und das Feld hat jetzt alles weg. Also im Prinzip...
Also das beste Denkbare ist jetzt, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen weniger wird. Selbst das ist nicht sicher.
Das passiert ja glaube ich nicht viel. Es gibt keine Abschreckung.
Ja, also ich hab da so einen ganz konkreten Fall. Ich hab bei Facebook mal vor der Landtagswahl in Schleswig-Holstein so ein bisschen geguckt, wie ich das so mache. Was macht die Partei so? Und hab da so gesehen, da ist ein Facebook-Post mit einem SA-Symbol. Und da so, hm, SA-Symbol in Deutschland, ist das nicht verboten?
Gibt es sogar einen eigenen Paragraf dafür?
Gibt es, tatsächlich hab ich das auch rausgefunden. Und dann so, ja, okay, was mach ich jetzt? Und dann war Möglichkeit A, ich melde es bei Facebook, wird vielleicht gesperrt, vielleicht auch nicht. In dem Fall war ich aber der Überzeugung, das ist für mich so ein krasser, ja, Gesetzesbruch einfach. Also da steht eine Strafe drauf. Und man darf das Symbol nur verwenden, wenn man es eben aus, weiß ich nicht, um die Geschichte zu erklären. Oder, weiß ich nicht, im Rahmen, ganz eng gesteckten Rahmen darf man es verwenden. Der Facebook-Post kam dem natürlich nicht gerecht. Und deshalb, ja, hab ich das dann angezeigt, wo hab's gemeldet. In dem Fall von solchen Sachen ist es auch so, dass du dich nicht, also du bist nicht das Opfer der Straftat, sondern es ist ja quasi etwas, dem muss die Polizei nachgehen, wenn sie Kenntnis davon hat. Und das hat aber auch recht lange gedauert, bis dann überhaupt irgendetwas passiert ist. Also meine Erfahrung ist da auch, dass vielleicht nicht alle Polizeibehörden da angemessen ausgestattet, ausgebildet sind, um dagegen vorzugehen. Ich hatte ein anderes Mal einen Fall während des Landtagswahlkampfes in Niedersachsen. Da hab ich für die Piraten kandidiert. Da hat uns jemand auch Drohungen geschickt per E-Mail. Zwei Schüsse einmal zwischen die Augen und Tod. Seid ihr oder so was? Genau, das war für die Polizei auch ein bisschen überfordernd. Interessant fand ich aber auch, dass ich bei einem anderen Fall, den ich hatte, dann auch zur Polizei gegangen bin. Wir haben das dann zur Anzeige gebracht. Dann hatte ich erst mal ein bisschen moralische Gewissensriss. Weil ich dachte, du bist ja gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Jetzt müssen jetzt die Vorratsdaten von diesen Menschen vielleicht rausgeholt werden, um herauszufinden, wer es ist. Stellt sich aber hinterher raus, oh nee, das war sein richtiger Name. Und wenn man den in der Suchmaschine eingibt, findet man ein Bild von ihm und seiner Frau, wie sie eine Wurst gekauft haben bei einem deutschen Fleischer. Wie sie ganz stolz diese Wurst in die Kamera zeigen, weil er hat in Spanien gelebt. Diese Praxiserfahrung der Anzeige ist auch noch mal eine ganz andere Sache. Eine Meldung ist schnell gemacht als Opfer. Aber andererseits denkt man auch, habe ich demjenigen gezeigt, was das für mich bedeutet hat? Nein, eigentlich nicht. Vielleicht wird sein Post gesperrt. Vielleicht wird sein Account gesperrt. Gut, macht er sich jetzt einen neuen. Aber der macht doch weiter wie bisher. Da würde ich auch jedem dazu raten, wenn es wirklich was Krasses ist und man gerade die Zeit übrig hat. Oder vielleicht ein bisschen Geld für einen Anwalt ist leider nicht kostenlos. Macht das einfach mal. Also es ist halt auch eine wichtige Erfahrung für sich selbst als Opfer zu sagen, ich schluck das jetzt nicht alles immer runter, ich lass das nicht mit mir machen, sondern erklär das mal bitte der Polizei.
Weil der Untertitel der Sendung ist, wie man die gesellschaftliche Debatte stärkt, ohne in die Meinungsfreiheit anzugreifen. Das geht mit dem Netz-CG schon mal nicht.
Nee, gar nicht. Also das ging aber vorher schon nicht. Also vorher war es ja schon so, dass Facebook nach Hausregeln entschieden hat, das ist erlaubt, das ist verboten. Gewalt, da ist man Großzüger bei Facebook, was halt auch so mit dem US-amerikanischen, ja vielleicht Verständnis davon, was im öffentlichen Raum akzeptabel ist, zusammenhängt. Beispielsweise Nippel von Frauenstille. Frauen geht gar nicht. Und da gab es mal einen ganz interessanten Fall, auch noch vor dem Netz-CG. Da gab es eine Seite, die hat sich ja so mit der AfD oder mit rechten Gruppen befasst, auch viel gepostet. Unter anderem satirische Beiträge von Extra 3. Da war auf einem Bild Hitler zu sehen in der Sprechblase, der sagt dann, ich bin zwar kein Nazi, aber... Die nächste Sprechblase, das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Das wurde dann von ganz vielen Leuten gemeldet. Wir haben das nachher dann untersucht in der Gruppe und haben gesehen, da gibt es gezielt Accounts auf Facebook von Rechten, die sagen, wir melden jetzt Gruppen oder Einzelpersonen, die uns unangenehm sind. Und zwar so oft, bis wir irgendwann an einen Sachbearbeiter gelangen bei Facebook, der wenig genug Bescheid weiß, um zu sagen, ach, das sperre ich jetzt mal. Und das ist in dem Fall dann auch passiert. Wegen einem extra drei Satire-Post wurde dann ein ganzer Account quasi hops genommen. Und zum Glück konnte das wieder rückgängig machen. Wie gesagt, in dem Fall war natürlich dann auch das Glück, dass da eine gewisse öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit da ist. Aber es ist vorher schon passiert. Das Problem ist, dass das NetzDG eben natürlich die Anreize verschiebt. Wenn ich als Betreiber weiß, da ist eine hohe Geldstrafe, die mich erwartet, wenn ich das nicht rechtzeitig lösche und ich bin mir nicht sicher, bzw. ich habe unterbezahlte Mitarbeiter, die sich ganz sicher nicht sicher sind, weil die keine juristische Vorbildung haben, dann nehme ich in Kauf, dass einfach mehr Sachen weggeschüttet werden, weil ich einfach die finanziellen Risiken scheue.
Jetzt sind wir sozusagen in diesem strafrechtlich relevanten Inhalt. Wie könnte man die juristisch unterbinden? Geht nicht so geil, das den Plattformen zu überlassen, ist auch nicht so gut. Was ich mich häufig gefragt habe, ist, von dem, was sie auch so erzählt haben, es gibt immer diese Einzeltäter, also jemand bedroht mich, jemand stalkt mich, aber das andere Phänomen ist ja auch immer, dass es dann so Wellen gibt. Es ist halt nicht nur ein Account, sondern es gibt halt Ziele, und diese Ziele werden dann von mehreren Accounts, Sockenpuppen, Retweetbots angegriffen. Und ich jetzt, als der da kein Programmierer ist, und sozusagen nicht wirklich weiß, wie das funktioniert, fragt sich aber trotzdem, ließe sich das nicht irgendwie so automatisieren, also dass du als User in deinem sozialen Account so Schwellen anmachen kannst und sagen kannst, okay, ich weiß irgendwie einen normalen Tag, ich hab 200.000 Follower, krieg aber nur drei Likes. Wenn ich irgendwie an einem Tag mehr als zehn Replies kriege, dann mal so stopp irgendwie, dann halte die mal irgendwo vor, oder filter die automatisch. Was ich halt total witzig finde, ist auch, wo ist denn das auf manchen Zeitungsseiten gibt, also die so Foren haben, da funktioniert das schon relativ zuverlässig. Also wir zeigen dir hier diese drei Kommentare an, da gibt's so noch fünf, die sind relativ wahrscheinlich nicht so geil, weil da irgendwie Schimpfwörter drin vorkommt. Also es gibt ja so Automatismen. Warum gibt es sowas nicht in den sozialen Netzwerken in dieser Form? Also in Nutzerhand sozusagen. Also nicht das Netzwerk entscheidet, was gut ist, sondern gibt den Nutzer so die Möglichkeit, so grobe Algorithmen einzustellen, mit der Möglichkeit, sich alles anzugucken, aber trotzdem so eine Art Firewall einzubauen. Gibt es da überhaupt Bestrebungen oder ist das zu schwierig?
Also die gab es ja mal ganz stark, gerade bei Twitter, also diese ganze Muting-Funktion zum Beispiel, dass man sowohl einzelne Hashtags, einzelne Personen oder auch einzelne Worte muten kann.
Aber da musst du ja immer noch konkret werden. Da musst du ja sagen, also dieses Hashtag und diese Person will ich nicht mehr hören.
Ja, aber jetzt mal um ein konkretes Beispiel zu nennen, also was eigentlich, glaube ich, wo ich mich mal ganz viel mit beschäftigen muss, war aus Versehen, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich daran erinnerst, an diese krasse Diskussion um den Jacob Applebaum drin herum, wo die ganze Szene irgendwie auseinandergeflogen ist und plötzlich irgendwie alle so und das Problem ist ja sozusagen, das hatten wir vorhin schon, dass das so, wenn man die ganze Zeit nur auf einem bestimmten Erregungslevel gehalten wird, ist es ganz schwer, es auf den Abstand zu nehmen. Und da sozusagen in so einer Situation zum Beispiel, damals gab es das noch nicht, die Chance haben, okay, erst mal alles, was hier mit Jacob Applebaum zu tun hat, erst mal auszustellen, hält ja sozusagen sehr viel Entspannung für diejenigen reingebracht, die entweder anders arbeiten wollen.
Man muss jetzt ganz kurz sagen, relativ prominente Figuren, Hackerkreisen, relativ harte Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe. Und darüber hat sich dann diese Szene, also am konkreten Fall und dann auch, was bedeutet das eigentlich, hat sich die Szene sehr entzweit, entdreit entviert, kann man sagen.
Genau, weil das natürlich auch gerade bei allen Leuten, bei allen Frauen, die sozusagen vielleicht mal was Ähnliches erlebt haben, es hat einfach unglaublich viele Emotionen ausgelöst. Es gab keine Chance, sich davor zu schützen, außer Twitter auszumachen, was für viele Menschen einfach beruflich keine Option mehr ist. Und da ist es sozusagen eine ganz kluge Sache von Twitter gewesen, dass, glaube ich, auf die Forschung von Karen Sinders zurückgegangen ist. Die ist eine Gamergate-Forscherin, die sich sehr viel damit beschäftigt hat, wie man eigentlich Nutzer dazu bringen kann, selbstbestimmt ihren Diskursraum zu gestalten. Darauf geht es zurück. Ähnlich ist da Mozilla mit dem Choral-Projekt in New York. Die haben Technologien entwickelt, wie man das auf Blogs so machen kann, dass gute Argumente und gute Diskutanten hochgerankt werden können. Es gab mal IMSEE, eine Facebook-ähnliche Plattform, wo man verschiedene Optionen hatte, sich Kommentare anzeigen zu lassen. Aber all das wurde eigentlich auch ein bisschen durch das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz zunichte gemacht, dass gesagt wurde, wir wollen eine Lösung für alle, eine, die dem Rechtsstaat genügt usw. Da wurden eigentlich konstruktivere Ansätze zunichte gemacht. Wenn man jetzt mal bei der Frage bleibt, wie kriegt man es hin, dass mehr gute Inhalte im Diskurs sind, könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, die großen Plattformen sollten nicht bloß Inhalte höher ranken, die viel Interaktion hervorrufen, sondern wo die Interaktion möglichst divers ist. Also wo die sozialen Gruppen oder die kulturellen Gruppen verschieden sind, also wo nicht nur Nazis einen Inhalt teilen, sondern wo möglicherweise unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche Gruppen Inhalt wichtig finden.
Aber wäre das dann nicht...
Und sowas wird gerade erdacht, das weiß ich. Das wäre auch eine Netzwerkgenuine Methode, um Inhalte anders zu steuern. Aber da stoßen sich im Regelfall alle Juristen, die sagen, wir wollen deutsches Recht durchgesetzt haben und nicht irgendwie anders Inhalte steuern oder so.
Wir können ja die deutschen Juristen jetzt mal deutschen Juristen sein lassen. Luca, vielleicht auch noch mal fragen wollen, einen Hate Shitstorm, würdest du sagen, man könnte den erkennen und auch semiautomatisch ablocken? Also wie gesagt, nicht inhaltlich, sondern sozusagen, dass man so Algorithmen hat, die sagen, na, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so geil, ich blende dir das mal aus, falls du es doch sehen willst, klick hier.
Bin ich, bin ich sehr kritisch. Also Greta versucht ja ein paar so Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, sie haben einmal den Qualitätsfilter und dann haben sie noch irgendwas für die Notifications, wo sie darüber gehen, Accounts, die häufig geblockt werden oder Accounts, die ständig Replies an andere Accounts schreiben, aber nie was zurückbekommen, dass die quasi automatisiert ausgefiltert werden. Also weil die halt einfach abusive Verhaltensweisen an den Tag legen und dann kann man die halt automatisiert etwas ausblenden, nicht komplett. Also sie sind grundsätzlich noch da. Das hilft etwas. Also das habe ich selber manchmal ausprobiert, wenn besonders viel am Twitter-Volumen gerade war, dass ich das so ein bisschen ausblende. Und dann ist es schon einmal ruhiger, dann kann man mit dem Rest besser umgehen. Aber bei Twitter ist dann das große Problem, die Replies sind ja trotzdem noch da. Und die Leute, die einem folgen, wenn sie auf ein Feed klicken, sehen trotzdem noch das Zeug. Manchmal wird es jetzt auch schon wieder versteckt, dann ist mehr, mehr Menschen oder mehr Replies anzeigen. Grundsätzlich bei Shitstorms, im Nachhinein kann man die eigentlich sehr gut analysieren. Also wenn es jetzt gerade gegen eine Person geht, dann kann man halt eben den Usernamen verwenden, beziehungsweise noch ein paar Begriffe rundherum. Und dann kann man sich anschauen, wir hatten sich da alle beteiligt. Aber das jetzt in Echtzeit zu machen und sofort zu sagen, okay, das ist ein positiver, es ist ein negativer Aufregungsschurm oder was auch immer, halte ich für sehr schwierig. Und man kann das halt für Einzelpersonen, kann man tatsächlich dann auch Bloglisten erstellen oder Mute-Listen, um es für die Person selber etwas erträglicher zu machen, aber das hilft halt der Gesamtdiskussion auch noch nicht.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, persönlich, also ich hab da überhaupt gar keine Hoffnung in irgendwelche technischen Lösungen, weil ganz ehrlich, das Problem sitzt ja leider vor der Tastatur so und alles, was das wegfiltert, ja, soll mir ein gutes Gefühl geben, aber ja, also ich muss sagen, so in den letzten zehn Jahren hab ich gelernt, damit sehr viel lockerer umzugehen, was nicht unbedingt erstrebenswert ist, ja, weil man sollte ja auch nicht sagen, nur derjenige sollte sich noch öffentlich äußern, der irgendwann, ja, das halt ausblenden kann. So sollte es ja nicht sein, aber ja, ich glaub, ich würd auch keine Filter installieren wollen, die mir quasi vorenthalten, was da passiert. Also wenn ich merke, da ist halt grad, braut sich was zusammen, dann guck ich einfach ein, zwei Tage nicht in Social Media rein, Punkt. Wobei ich auch sagen muss, ist was vollkommen anderes, wenn man eine öffentliche Person ist, als wenn man jetzt beispielsweise irgendwie 17 ist und irgendwie fünf Leute aus der eigenen Klasse schreiben öffentlich über einen im Internet, du bist scheiße. Dann ist es halt kein Shitstorm von 5000 Leuten. Ja, aber es sind vielleicht die 5000 Leute, die mir in meinem Leben am meisten wehtun können, zu einer Zeit, wo ich unglaublich verletzlich bin. Und ich stelle mir das sehr schwierig vor, das halt irgendwie technisch lösen zu wollen. Ich wäre auch sehr kritisch gegenüber irgendwelchen Filtern, die vielleicht ranken nach Diversität usw. Also so begrüßenswert vielleicht die Effekte im Großen und Ganzen sind. Ich würde mir als Nutzer bevormundet vorkommen. Also ich möchte die Möglichkeit haben, selber solche Einstellungen vorzunehmen, wenn ich sie möchte. Aber was ich grundsätzlich bei Facebook gerne hätte, wäre einfach einen vollkommen selbstbestellten Filter zu 100%.
Aber das ist ja das, was ich gefragt habe. Ich meinte ja exakt nicht, sollen die Netzwerke das irgendwie für mich festlegen, sondern warum ist es, genau was du gesagt hast, warum ist es nicht so, dass ich als User die Möglichkeit habe, dieses Erlebnis freier zu gestalten? Also eben halt mich zu entscheiden, ich möchte gerne diesen Filter, den ihr mir da anbietet, anwenden oder nicht. Und wann immer der Filter anschickt, auch dass ich jedes Mal die Gelegenheit habe zu sagen, ja okay, danke, aber ich will trotzdem reingucken.
Ja, also ich hätte gerne die volle Wahlmöglichkeit. Das wäre so die beste Lösung, finde ich. Weil dann kann man auch selber gucken, was funktioniert für mich persönlich und was funktioniert nicht und kann es vielleicht anpassen.
Ne, das frage ich gleich. Wir hören jetzt noch Musik und dann frage ich euch mal nach Klarnahmenzwang. Weil das ist ja, also wenn die Gesetzgebung nicht funktioniert und der automatische Filter nicht, dann gibt es ja Leute, die sagen, der Klarnahmenzwang, der wird auf jeden Fall alles so machen, dass es unfassbar gut wird. Aber bevor wir dieses Wundermittel ausprobieren, hören wir es den Starsong von Lee Rose Ware. So, ist ja nur noch eine halbe Stunde. Wir müssen dann gleich mal darüber reden, wie es denn jetzt in Zukunft eigentlich so wird mit diesem Netz, in dem es diesen ganzen Hass gibt, ob das so bleibt oder ob man das vielleicht alles anders machen kann. Aber vorher noch, also vor den großen Visionen, das kleine Wundermittel. Es gibt ja häufig Leute und also wirklich, das kommt aus den verschiedensten Ecken und auch immer wieder. Wer war denn das neulich? Irgendjemand hat neulich bei Twitter gesagt so, ja, wer unter Pseudonym antwortet, dem antworte ich gar nicht erst. Nur der Klarnamenzwang ist die reine Lehre und verhindert allen Hass im Netz. Und man mag man im Tonfall schon annehmen, dass ich nicht so ganz glaube, aber noch mal kurz, weil das ist schon was, wenn wir darüber reden. Das ist ja auch ein Argument, das immer kommt. Wir müssen es auch hier wenigstens kurz vorkommen lassen. Deswegen erstens an euch die Frage, was ist die Idee, also warum kommen Leute darauf, dass Klarnamenzwang möglicherweise für weniger Hass im Netz sorgen könnte?
Ja, so ein Vorurteil ist ja, dass der Hass nur daherkommt, dass man anonym ist. Das ist so eine grundsätzliche Annahme, bei der man sagt, naja, so ins Gesicht würde ich das jemandem ja nicht sagen. Und von daher, weil viele Leute auch online anders unterwegs sind mit Nicknames, ist dann der Verdacht oder der Schuldige schlecht gefunden, weil der kann ja unmöglich vor der Tastatur sitzen. Das liegt anscheinend daran, dass die Leute sich halt eben unter Pseudonym oder Anonym äußern können. Und das ist so eine der Standardvermutungen. Wobei man sagen muss, also da ist natürlich auch so ein Hintergedanke bei, je nachdem wer es sagt dabei. Man muss ja auch sagen, wenn wir alle mit Klarnamen im Netz unterwegs wären, das heißt mit Vornamen, Nachnamen überall angemeldet werden, dann wäre es ja für die Werbewirtschaft auch viel einfacher, uns alles Mögliche zu verkaufen. Das heißt, gerade wenn bestimmte Akteure, die auch ein gesundes Eigeninteresse in der Hinsicht dran haben, uns erzählen wollen, ja melde dich überall lieber mit Vornamen, Nachnamen, am besten noch mit Passnummer und Geburtstag an. Vorsicht.
Okay, aber wir haben heute schon auch konkret ein Beispiel gehört, dass Professor Doktor, ich schieß dich tot, durchaus im Klarnamen mit unterwegs ist. Was mich aber interessieren würde ist, eine von euch hatte mir im Vorfeld erzählt, es gab schon mal ein größeres Sozialexperiment, wo genau das ausprobiert worden ist, wo man dann mal gucken konnte, was bringt denn jetzt dieser Klarnamenzwang?
Ja, das war ich. Und zwar gab es mal einen Klarnamenzwang in sozialen Netzwerken und auf Internetseiten, die politische Nachrichten berichten, und zwar in Südkorea für ein paar Jahre. Und da gab es im Nachhinein auch ziemlich viel interessante Forschung, die haben sich angeguckt, hat denn das Aufkommen von Shitstorms oder von Hassbotschaften dann wirklich abgenommen dadurch. Und die kommen zu dem Ergebnis, nee, also wenn überhaupt, dann kann man sagen, vielleicht ein oder zwei Prozent weniger an Hassnachrichten, aber ob das jetzt darauf zurückzuführen ist, so kann man auch nicht genau sagen. Grundsätzlich haben die Studien alle gezeigt, dass wenn jemand wirklich Hass erfüllt ist und bereit ist, jemanden bestimmte Dinge vor den Lads zu knallen, dann macht er das mit und ohne Doktortitel, so wie in meinem Beispiel. Und das ist leider so. Und in Südkorea kommt auch noch mal dazu, dass die ganze Geschichte dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahrens auch recht krude war. Und zwar war der Auslöser ein veritabler Shitstorm, so einer der ersten größeren Shitstorms, die Südkorea erlebt hat. Und zwar hat jemand gefilmt, wie eine Hundehalterin in der Bahn unterwegs war und ihr Hund hat dann ein Geschäft verrichtet und sie ist dann einfach mit dem Hund rausgegangen und jemand hatte das gefilmt und ins Netz gestellt. Und diese Frau ist dann zum Hassobjekt der gesamten Nation geworden. Und daraufhin hat die Regierung dann gesagt, wir müssen jetzt was machen. Und das Interessante ist, dass das Gesetz, was dann danach beschlossen wurde, nicht nur beinhaltete, dass Internetseiten, die mehr als 300.000 Nutzer haben, dann Leute zwingen müssen, mit echten Namen sich anzumelden, sondern auch, dass man zwölf Tage vor der Wahl nur noch mit Klarnamen, also mit richtigen Namen, in Blogs und so weiter politische Kommentare oder Kommentare zu Kommentaren verfassen darf. Was ja durchaus ein politisches Geschmäckle hat. Genau, aber zum Glück gibt es ja die Klarnamenpflicht, wurde dann irgendwann auch abgeschafft in Südkorea. Und zwar war es so, dass es eine kleine Sicherheitslücke in einem Social-Network gab. Und daraufhin haben ganz viele Leute Daten rausgetragen. Das ist natürlich was komplett anderes, wenn ich da als Bibi Blocksberg registriert bin. Oder mit Vor- und Nachnamen. Und vielleicht noch Geburtsdatum und Passnummer. Und ja, das hat so die Einstellung zu solchen Fragen nachhaltig verändert. Ich muss zu meiner Schande gestehen, ich weiß nicht, wie es heute aussieht. Aber zu dieser Phase in Südkorea gibt es auf jeden Fall sehr gute Studien, die alle sagen, so ist Quatsch.
So, also da halte ich mal fest. Mit der juristischen Keule wird das nicht so richtig. Mit der automatischen technischen Lösung wird das auch nicht so richtig. Und Gottverdammt noch mal, der Klarnamenzwang bringt das auch nicht. Jetzt wollte ich gerade fragen, wie kriegen wir den Hass im Netz im Griff? Aber ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das die richtige Frage ist. Weil ich muss mal ein sehr altes Interview zitieren. Mit Glenn Greenwald hatten wir das mal. Also der Journalist, der diesnotenfalls mit sozusagen am Anfang verwaltet und den ans Licht gebracht hat. Und das war so ein Jahr oder zwei nach den Edward-Snoten-Enhüllungen. Und haben ihn gefragt, naja, also irgendwie, jetzt ist ja wirklich, also schwarz auf weiß, alles wird überwacht, Geheimdienste machen unsere Pakete auf und bauen Chips in den Computer rein, Mikrowellen strahlen, hören Handykabel ab. Also das Irrsinnigste, was man sich ausdenken kann, ist alles wahr. Und trotzdem gibt es Leute, die sagen, ja Überwachung ist auch so egal. Er sagt, naja, er geht davon aus, es gibt halt einfach so pro Gesellschaft so 20 bis 30 Prozent Leute, die merken es einfach nicht oder die werden vom System nicht genug unterdrückt, denen geht es gut. Man muss damit leben, dass die da sind. Und muss sich nur den Rest kümmern. Analog dazu, kann man Hass im Netz im Griff kriegen oder muss man einfach damit leben, dass man sagt, also früher haben die halt in den Stammtischkneipen vor sich hin abgehast, jetzt haben sie einfach eine öffentliche Bühne. Das ist halt so, wir müssen irgendwie alle resilient werden, damit umgehen oder kann man das irgendwie in den Griff bekommen, wie auch immer das aussehen soll. Hat jemand eine Lösung?
Also ich, ja danke, ich wird, also wir sind in letzter Zeit mal so zwei Sachen aufgefallen. Die werden Hass im Netz nicht eliminieren. Aber es geht ja auch nicht darum sozusagen, den Mund tot zu machen, sondern tatsächlich sozusagen eine Gesellschaft zu ermöglichen irgendwie. Also es geht darum, eine Balance zu haben. Ich meine, was natürlich total dämlich ist, wir reden jetzt seit zwei Jahren intensivst über Hass im Netz, über Hate Speech, über Bots, über alles Mögliche, über Inhalte, wo ich neugierig total eins auf die Decke gekriegt habe, weil ich sie auf Netzpolitik jetzt unliebsam bezeichnet habe. Also Inhalte, die wie Hass, wie terroristische Inhalte, wie Kinderpornografie, die im Regelfall sozusagen an hiesige Normen stoßen und die man gerne raus haben will. Und gleichzeitig haben wir halt sozusagen hier in Deutschland ein EU-Heberrecht, was gerade auf europäischer Ebene erweitert werden soll, was die Verbreitung von qualitativ hochwertigen Inhalten wie Presseartikeln, aber auch anderen Werken eigentlich reduzieren soll. Und es macht halt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass wir uns einerseits darüber aufregen, dass sozusagen die Netzwerke mit allem möglichen Scheiß geflutet werden. Und wir gleichzeitig sozusagen die Verbreitung von guten Inhalten künstlich behindern.
Warte, ich hab mich neulich zu was gelesen. Also gerade heute irgendjemand, der meinte so, na ja, es zeichnet sich langsam ab, dass die ganzen großen Medien Paywalls einmal, also man muss bezahlen, um Artikel zu lesen. Das heißt, es gibt ein wohlkuratiertes, gut schmeckendes Internet für alle Leute, die sich das leisten können und lasst den armen Pöbel doch einfach in den Hassnetzwerken abhängen.
Ja, aber wir haben halt sozusagen, ich weiß nicht genau, wir haben jetzt gestern schon wieder so eine Waage gehabt. Also ich sitze ja hier quasi, naja, also nicht offiziell für die SPD. Also ich bin ja auch grün, aber ich kooperiere auch mit den meisten bis auf die AfD. Also wie wir auch immer, auf jeden Fall gibt es sozusagen natürlich das Problem, dass es eine massive Unzufriedenheit der Menschen mit der Politik gibt. Und zwar glaube ich aus mehreren Gründen zu Recht. Also einerseits haben wir natürlich, seitdem wir das Netz haben und seitdem wir die Globalisierung haben, auf nationalstaatlicher Ebene ganz viel Handlungsoptionen eingeboost. Und es gehen ganz viele Sachen nicht voran und es macht die Leute unzufrieden. Wir brauchen für ganz viele wirtschaftliche und ökologische Probleme internationale Lösungen. Und gerade haben wir sozusagen ein internationales Spiel, wo sozusagen der Populismus zurückkehrt, wo die Kriegsbedrohungen zurückkehrt und wo alles andere als zufriedenstellend ist. Also ich verstehe die Unzufriedenheit von den Menschen so. Und ich glaube, dass man den Hass auch mal als einen Ausdruck von menschlichem Leid sehen muss. Und was mich in letzter Zeit auf der anderen Seite auch beschäftigt tatsächlich, war die Frage, was wäre eigentlich, wenn man mal nicht gegen den einzelnen Hater vorgehen würde, sondern die Masse an Hass aggregieren würde und mal gucken würde, hängt das zusammen mit bestimmten ökologischen Faktoren, zum Beispiel mit Lärm und Abgas. Wie ist das? Gibt es eigentlich einen Zusammenhang zwischen Aggression und der Grundversorgung von Menschen international? Wir haben heute soziale Netzwerke, die uns unglaublich sensible Analysen über Menschen ermöglichen und die werden aber eigentlich gegen Menschen verwendet. Was wäre eigentlich, wenn man sozusagen gucken würde, was drückt eigentlich dieser Hass aggregiert aus?
Du meinst, wenn man die soziale Netzwerke nicht dazu benutzen könnte, würde man sagen, was können wir ihnen am besten verkaufen, sondern was fehlt ihnen eigentlich?
Ja, also wenn man zum Beispiel, es gibt diese Abida, ein ganz tolles Forschungsnetzwerk, Abida heißt das, die machen so Big Data-Analysen aus einer disziplinären Perspektive und die hatten neulich eine ganz tolles Gutachten zum Thema Nudging. Und da war sozusagen ein Beispiel, Facebook ist in der Lage, Du müssen das Mikrofon ein bisschen eher wieder. Facebook ist in der Lage, heute sowas wie Selbstmordgefährdung zu erkennen. Und je nach Land können dann halt zum Beispiel Freunde informiert werden, dass die sich da mal melden oder könnte auch mal Sozialarbeiter vorbei geschickt werden oder auch Polizei oder auch, ich mein, man kann auch live gestreamt werden, dann kommt halt nur der Krankenwagen so, ne? Das ist richtig schlecht. Aber es gibt es halt in Amerika auch alles. Aber für mich ist sozusagen das eigentlich eine totale Ressourcenverschwendung und auch gefährlich, dass sozusagen so ein Unternehmen so auf Abweichungen wie Krankheit oder wie irgendwas anderes sozusagen drauf gehen kann. Aber natürlich, wenn Facebook, so wie Zuckerberg in seinem Manifest versprochen hat, in der Lage ist automatisiert, sowohl individuelle und kollektive Risiken zu erkennen, könnte man natürlich das auch wirklich benutzen, um herauszufinden, wo kommen die denn her, was könnte man sozusagen auf übergeordneter Ebene tun, um die Risiken für die einzelnen Menschen zu begrenzen, damit es denen besser geht.
Aber dahinter steckt ja sozusagen die optimistische Annahme, der Mensch hasst nicht, wenn es ihm nur gut genug geht.
Ich denke auf jeden Fall, dass sozusagen der Hass eine ganz normale Reaktion ist, wenn Menschen unter Druck, unter Existenzdruck sich fühlen und sie tun seit jeher irgendwie den nächstbesten Nachbarn als Hassobjekt identifizieren. Es ist sozusagen was relativ Normales. Es funktioniert aber sozusagen nicht, wenn eigentlich alle immer mehr unter Druck stehen.
Ja, also dem würde ich wieder sprechen. Also ich würde gerne so eine positive Einstellung haben und immer bei jedem, der mir schreibt, ach ja, morgen Gruppenvergewaltigung, 9 Uhr, wie immer, würde ich dann denken, oh ja, der ist bestimmt sehr missverstanden. Und eigentlich ist das ein total netter Mensch. Er lebt einfach nur in ganz schlimmen Bedingungen. Ja, also ich glaube, das ist gemischt. Also vielleicht teilweise Leute, denen geht es wirklich irgendwie wirtschaftlich schlecht. Aber es ist, mein Gott, mir ging es in meinem Leben auch nicht wirtschaftlich immer gut. Das ist trotzdem kein Grund, dann halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, also gruppenbezogenen Hass raushängen zu lassen. Also eine Freundin von mir engagiert sich ganz stark im Bereich Diskriminierung von Muslimen. Was die abkriegt, ist nur ein Bruchteil von dem, wovon ich jemals geträumt habe, so was ich abkriege. Also es ist halt wirklich nochmal eine andere Kategorie. Und da fällt es mir wirklich schwer zu sagen, naja, oder zu glauben, naja, wenn die Gesellschaft ein bisschen besser ist, wenn wir mehr Sozialabgaben und so weiter haben, dann hört das auf. Ich glaube, das hört nicht auf. Es gab schon immer beispielsweise harte Nazis, harte Frauenfeinde in dieser Gesellschaft. Die wird es auch immer weitergeben. Und gerade im Kontext von MeToo, also dem Hashtag, unter dem ganz viele Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund oder die vielleicht auch anders aussehen, als wir uns so den Stereotype Deutsche vorstellen, über ihre Erfahrungen geschrieben haben. Was ich da an Hass oder Gehässigkeit gesehen hab, das ist halt purer Alltagsrassismus. Und die Leute sehen sich ja auch selbst nicht als Hater, sondern naja, das wird man einfach ja wohl noch mal sagen dürfen.
Aber siehst du das nicht auch sozusagen, dass es mega spannend wäre, wenn Facebook zum Beispiel mal damit rausrücken würde, wie sozusagen global in den unterschiedlichen Communities, in den unterschiedlichen Konflikten, in den unterschiedlichen sozialen Terrain sozusagen so dieses ganze Hassproblem aussieht. Also die haben ja die Daten. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass keiner die hätte. Ich weiß, dass es jetzt nur Vermutungen sind.
Ich würde schon unterschreiben, dass das spannend ist, sie anzugucken. Ich habe auch mal eine Zweifel, ob das sozusagen nur ein Problem zweiter Eben ist. Also ob das nur ist, was ist, was eine Grundlage hat und wenn man diese Grundlage ändert, dass es dann ganz weggeht. Aber das ist glaube ich eine Frage, ich würde gern Luca noch fragen, was er von der These oder Theorie hält.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz eine Sache reinfügen?
Aber ganz kurz.
Ja, also zum Beispiel was total schade ist, dass so klassische Institutionen die Rechtsradikalismus bekämpfen, wie die Amadeo-Antonio-Stiftung, dass die halt sozusagen seit den 90ern, also wurde diese Frage, was haben eigentlich Rassismen mit einem sozialen Stand zu tun? Die Frage, da gibt es keine Studien mehr zu. Und heute hätten wir die Möglichkeit diese Daten mal auszuwerten. Ob das in Zusammenhang gibt oder nicht.
Herr Hammer?
Ich glaube, dass ganz viel von dem Hass, den zumindest ich jetzt im Netz beobachte, auf falschen Annahmen auch passiert. Dort spielt sicherlich auch das Umfeld der Personen, die dann tatsächlich reagieren, eine gewisse Rolle. Aber ich glaube trotzdem auch, weil ich es bei Einzelpersonen manchmal verfolge, fälle es so weit, dass ich ein bisschen Verständnis davon habe, wer die Personen sind. Denen Personen geht es nicht unbedingt schlecht. Aber manchmal haben sie das Gefühl, dass es ihnen schlecht geht. Oder dass andere was besser haben, was mehr haben. Was sicherlich sehr menschlich ist. Das Gras auf der anderen Seite ist immer grüner. Aber von der Ungerechtigkeit im Alltag auf diese Gruppe ist das Problem zu schließen, ist sehr schwierig. Und ich glaube halt auch nicht nur, weil kleine Ungerechtigkeiten beseitigt werden, dass es insgesamt besser wird. Aber ich glaube sehr wohl, dass es, wenn es den Menschen insgesamt besser geht, weniger konkrete Feingruppen gibt.
Ja, was ich auch nochmal anmerken wollte, ich finde das total gut, sich bei Diskussionen über Hass im Netz auch sehr viel mit den Tätern auseinanderzusetzen. Ich würde mir allerdings wünschen, dass stärker auch die Opferperspektive zur Sprache kommt. Denn natürlich können wir uns damit auseinandersetzen. Na ja, geht es den Tätern jetzt schlecht? Könnte es den Tätern noch besser werden? Würden sie dann keine Täter mehr sein? Was ich mich allerdings auch frage, ist auch ganz konkret in meinem Umfeld, was kann ich tun, damit Menschen mit der Situation, wie sie jetzt nun gerade sind, die ich kurzfristig auch als eine Person nicht ändern kann, besser klarkommen können. Und wir können uns ja alle darauf einrichten, selbst wenn es jetzt irgendwie daran liegen würde, dass es uns ökonomisch schlecht geht. Wobei, würde ich zweifeln, in Deutschland geht es wirtschaftlich sehr gut. Und nicht alle Rechten sind geringverdiener. Das muss man halt auch so sehen. Nicht alle Frauenfeinde sind geringverdiener. Das ist bei weitem nicht so. Also wir können das nicht kurzfristig lösen. Was können wir denn machen, um den Leuten den Rücken zu stärken? Ich hab da viel auch mit Freundinnen, die in ähnlichen Situationen waren, wie ich drüber gesprochen. Und die sagen alle, wir wünschen uns mehr Unterstützung. Wie oft ist es dann so, dass man irgendwas auf Facebook sieht, da wird jemand angegangen und da denkt man sich, ich möchte nicht in die Schusslinie geraten. Bloß nicht hier irgendwie einmischen. Dabei wäre es ganz einfach, sich mal einzuklinken, einfach den Personen den Rücken zu stärken. Mir persönlich gibt es extrem viel, wenn ich Twitter oder Facebook aufmache. Dann sehe ich ganz kruden Mist. Dann hat aber jemand schon drunter kommentiert und gesagt, dass es Mist ist, dass ich das gar nicht mehr machen muss. Solche Dinge kann jeder von uns machen. Dafür braucht es kein Gesetz. Da braucht es den gesunden Menschenverstand zu. Und mehr Mut, Zivilcourage. Genauso wie ich in der Bahn einschreite, wenn ich sehe, jemand wird fremdenfeindlich belästigt, muss ich das eigentlich auch online machen. Das ist ganz, ganz klar. Wechseln geht da nicht.
Also im Prinzip ja. Und ich frage mich dann aber immer, das Problem an diesem sozialen Netzwerk ist ja momentan, das klang vorhin schon mal an, diese Interaktion. Also je mehr Interaktion etwas hat, desto höher wird es gerankt, desto sichtbarer wird es also. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich hingehe und nochmal auf etwas reagiere, was mistransportiert, helfe ich gleichzeitig dabei, es sichtbarer zu machen.
Das stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Aber trotzdem kann ich dir sagen, ich als Opfer, mir gibt es sehr viel, das zu lesen.
Ich wollte die Frage weiter stellen, auf welche Form man das machen soll. Also noch eine kleine Schleife. Wir haben in einer letzten Sendung über Mastodon geredet. Und Mastodon hat sich dagegen entschieden, so etwas wie Quotetweets zu machen. Auf Twitter geht es ja, ich kann einen Tweet, in meinen Tweet einbetten und dann dazu was schreiben. Das geht bei Mastodon nicht, sondern du kannst einen Tweet schreiben und dann steht da ein Link zu einem anderen Post. Das heißt, du musst extra klicken. Die Argumentation dahinter war, die Erregungs-Schleifen funktionieren vor allen Dingen auch darüber, dass ich etwas in meinen Tweet einbetten kann und sage, guck mal, wie scheiße das ist. Deswegen frage ich mich und ich habe das an mir selbst beobachtet und habe festgestellt, das stimmt. Also in dem Moment, wo ich das nicht mehr machen kann, tendiere ich dazu, weniger erregt zu schreiben. Und was ich jetzt fragen wollte ist, also ich habe gehört, ja, das ist hilfreich für die Opfer, wenn sich da geäußert wird, aber welche Art und Weise macht man das, um sozusagen gleichzeitig sichtbar machen zu verhindern? Also lieber öffentlich replying oder lieber DM oder egal, Hauptsache man sagt überhaupt irgendwas.
Nee, also DM finde ich persönlich, klar ist nett, aber gleichzeitig ist es halt auch so das Statement so, hey, ich äußere mich nicht öffentlich dazu. So ich flüsse das dir ins Ohr, dass ich eigentlich total zu dir stehe. Und das ist halt genauso, wenn man irgendwie in der Schule gemobbt wird und dann kommt jemand zu einem so, hey, nicht allen sagen, aber ich stehe voll hinter dir. Das ist dann halt ein bisschen traurig. Das ist sehr traurig. Nur wenn es jemand auch so schreibt, ich möchte das halt nicht irgendwie dem Bereich weitergehen, kann ich nachvollziehen, trotzdem wird es mich in den meisten Fällen mehr freuen, wenn jemand da halt direkt Positionen bezieht. Wobei für mich natürlich der Unterschied ist, was ist der Original Ausgangspost? Wenn irgendjemand, keine Ahnung, eine Photoshop-Nacktbild-Retouche von mir irgendwo gestellt hat und aus irgendwelchen rechtlichen Gründen kriege ich es nicht weg und ganz viele Leute kommentieren da drunter, würde ich vielleicht sagen, ja, schreib mir lieber eine DM. Oder eine Privatnachricht. Aber in den meisten Fällen geht es ja halt einfach nur, dass jemand irgendwas doof findet, was ich sage, wo ich denke, das finde ich jetzt nicht schlimm, wenn das hochgerankt wird. Obwohl es mich natürlich stört, wenn in der Aktion so Sachen hochrankt. Oder was ich aber auch mache, und da muss ich mich schuldig bekennen, ich binde manchmal auch Postings von anderen ein, weil das auch eine ganz typische Strategie ist, damit umzugehen. Natürlich kann ich in meinem stillen Camer-Line Leuten zeigen, guck mal, womit ich konfrontiert werde, weil ich mich zu diesem Thema äußere, aber ich mach das natürlich auch öffentlich. Also ich nehme auch einzelne Tweets, Screenshots, stelle die ins Netz oder binde die ein und sag mal, guck mal, geht es dir noch gut oder so. Dann weiß ich nicht, damit ich damit nicht alleine bin. Und ich finde es auch okay, wenn andere Leute das machen.
Wie gesagt, unsicher.
Vielleicht würde ich das Thema noch auf eine andere Ebene heben, sozusagen in der Politik, wenn man wirklich politische Sachen sagt, sowohl ich bei Netzpolitik, aber auch andere Politiker, die ich kenne. Es ist oft das Problem, dass die kritischen Kommentare oft in den Kommentarspaten unter den Blogs eingehen und das Lob per E-Mail oder per Telefon. Natürlich freuen wir uns total über das Lob und per E-Mail und per Telefon. Aber es ist sozusagen für die Meinungsbildung in den Gruppen, wo wir uns bewegen, super schwierig, weil wir sozusagen unseren Kollegen erklären müssen, warum wir von außen nur Wind kriegen, obwohl wir in sozusagen eigentlich auch noch andere, also die Meinung, also eigentlich wäre es gut. Ich glaube, dass sich halt sozusagen unglaublich viele normale Leute nicht in die Kommentarspalten verirren, weil da halt schon mal so viel Scheiß läuft. Obwohl die, wenn sie gut läuft, unglaublich interessant sind, weil man kann durch die Kommentarspalten ganz viel diskutieren, was man nicht im Artikel diskutieren kann. Also ich finde die sehr, sehr spannend, aber da verirren sich halt wenig Menschen zu tun, Menschen hin, die da nicht hin müssen, weil einfach aus Zeitgründen und so, weil sie verrufen sind. Aber es wäre manchmal hilfreich, wenn die Leute auch mal unten drunter gucken würden. Ich gucke manchmal Tweets unten drunter, wenn ich weiß, das ist jetzt hier auf jeden Fall wirklich politisch. Und dann mische ich mich auch mal ein, wenn ich denjenigen mag und da nur Gegenwind kommt. Aber der Gegenwind öffentlich ist wesentlich härter.
Aber das ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen deprimierend. Also an der öffentlichen Wand ist es hart. Deswegen traut das dann selbstverfahren das System auch.
Ja, ich finde das ist unterschiedlich von Medium zu Medium und von Forum, Kommentarspalte zu Kommentarspalte. Das ist halt wie so ein Teich. Also wenn ein Teich einmal so zu viele Eigenheit und Blätter ist, der euphotrophiert, dann stirbt alles darin. Da bleiben halt irgendwann nur so kleine Blaualgen drin. Ja, so eine Monokultur. Genauso kann man sich einen Online-Forum vorstellen, wenn man nicht ordentlich moderiert. Also irgendwann geht dann alles Leben raus. Es bleiben dann halt nur noch einige wenige, die dann halt den Ton angeben. Und auch alle niedermachen, die gegenreden. Und deshalb ist es ganz wichtig, immer zu gucken, dass man moderiert. Also ich bin sehr für die Pressefreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit. Aber ich bin gleichzeitig auch ein Mensch, der sagt, meine Kommentarspalte in meinem Blog, da bestimme ich. Also ich gehe ja auch nicht zu jemandem anderen. Und auf eine Party und kacke ihm auf den Tisch. Und genauso möchte ich in meinen Kommentarspalten schalte ich nichts frei, wo irgendwie links zu rechten Blogs gehen. Oder wo jemand halt irgendwie mir droht. Warum soll ich einen Kommentar mit Drohungen über mich freischalten? Und genauso finde ich das auch okay, wenn Nachrichtenseiten moderieren. Und ich finde es auch krass, dass es mittlerweile immer mehr Nachrichtenseiten gibt, die sagen, ich komme nicht hinterher mit der Moderation, oder wir kommen nicht hinterher. Es gibt einfach keine Kommentarfunktion mehr. Aber es ist auch aus dem Grund, und ich finde es auch konsequent zu sagen, wenn man nicht genug Kapazitäten hat, um das zu moderieren, dann machen wir es nicht. Das finde ich absolut richtig. Weil es beeinflusst Menschen auch, wenn ich einen Artikel lese und darunter einfach nur aus Interesse gucke, was war das Meistgelesende, Meistgeleigte. Und wenn das wirklich volksverhetzendes Kram ist oder wirklich verletzendes Zeug, beleidigendes, auch inhaltlich gar nicht mehrwertig, dann verschiebt das die Debatte in eine ganz, ganz grüne Richtung, wo ich mich dann natürlich nicht wohl genug fühle, um zu denken, ach ja, da kommentiere ich jetzt mal.
Das finde ich auch ganz interessant, weil man oft hat so fast schon, ich nehme es als Reflex wahr, wenn ein Medium sagt, wir stellen Kommentare ganz ein, oder sagt, nur bei ausgewählten Artikeln stellen wir eine Kommentarmöglichkeit zur Verfügung. Das ist so eine Reflexreaktion. Immer so, ja, aber das ist doch gerade das Geile am Internet, das alle immer alles überall sagen wollen. Wo ich auch so denke, naja, aber vielleicht ist es tatsächlich besser, wenn man sozusagen gezielt Diskussionen zulässt und die dann aber auch gut durchmoderiert.
Ich denke mir halt, ich möchte meine Leser halt auch schützen irgendwo. Ich möchte meine Leser davor schützen, dass sie persönlich angegangen werden, dass sie bedroht werden, beleidigt werden. Ich möchte in meinem Block einen Raum schaffen, wo Menschen sich nicht schämen müssen für ihre Geschlecht, für ihre Sexualität, für ihre Herkunft, was auch immer. Und das bedeutet für mich eben auch, wenn ich über die AfD schreibe, bei Themen, wo einfach dann auch mal auf den Knopfdruck plötzlich 20 Posts auf einmal kommen, dass ich die vorher freischalte. Das ist dann doof für die Diskussion, weil ich komme da nicht hinterher. Aber ansonsten hätte ich halt wirklich grues Zeug da stehen, wo sich niemand mehr wohlfühlen würde, zu sagen, ich kommentiere hier.
Also öffentlich loben, auch mal durch moderieren. Luca Hammer, hast du noch ein Rat oder Mitschlag für uns? Alles klar. Dann bedanke ich mich bei euch, dass ihr heute hier wart und wir über dieses... Doch, ja.
Bitte was?
Ich bekomme eine... Was? Mir wird gerade bedeutet, dass ich das machen soll, was ich eh gerade machen wollte. Aber vorher wollte ich mich noch bedanken bei Julia Krüger, Luca Hammer und Katharina Nocun, die hier waren und mit mir über dieses echt schwierige Thema geredet haben. Es gibt Sendungen, wo ich denke, die Musik, man muss das, aber ich war echt froh, zwischendurch ein bisschen Luft holen zu können. War schon ganz gut. Danke, dass ihr das mit mir durchgemacht habt. Und genau, wie jetzt zum Ende der Sendung ist, ich gehört noch zwei Hinweise. Das eine ist, vom 17. bis 18. November gibt es die Konferenz Bits und Bäume für Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit. Also vielleicht ist da auch ein Ort, wo man die Welt ein bisschen besser machen kann, die im Endeffekt dazu führt, dass wir weniger Hass haben. Da geht es, wie gesagt, um die Bereiche Digitalisierung und Ökologie zusammengehen. Und das andere, dass sich wahrscheinlich alle fragen, die irgendwas mit Chaos zu hören ist, gibt es einen Kongress? Ja. Wo ist der in Leipzig? Wann gibt es Tickets? Tickets gibt es im Vorverkauf. Am 8. November um 12, am 11. November um 14 Uhr und am 21. November um 21 Uhr. Dann gibt es also auf der Webseite dann die Ticketverkaufstermine. Fahrt hin, habt Spaß, hinterlasst uns Kommentare, lobt uns öffentlich, wenn ihr es habt. Ansonsten hab ich nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter, seid lieb, nett und respektvoll zueinander und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Und don't forget I'm in your extended network.